d'abord la mort chantal m
la mère gros sur la ligue en clair a des
reflets d'argent travers
leur fait fort
c'est mon coeur
il ya aussi à monsieur est à distinguer
qui est un un vrai chanteur de charme
comme chez cogedim été un petit peu
moustache une charmante s'appelle jean
sablon
et passer ça peut me voir
ça fait que 10 des bois
doit peut-être voir ce soir j'ai taddei
de tous
je jette un regard
pour quelles raisons jeu ce soir
passez-vous
benoît est aussi un autre garçon qui
s'appelle
tino rossi si si si si si c'est plus
petit papa noël quand tu descendras
messieurs avec des remous parmi les
valeurs les temps
mon petit papa noël quand tu descendras
parmi les annuler
mon sourire
amar que c'était pareil quand j'ai
commencé à faire du cinématographe
on m'accuse et très vite de chercher à
imiter les partenaires que j'avais à
l'écran ainsi j'ai commencé dans un film
il s'appelait à grands patrons et dont
la vedette était pierre fresnay à vous
connaissez tous ces vers de verlaine qui
commence par eux j'ai fait souvent sur
l'avs étrange et pénétrant une femme
inconnue et que j'aime et qui m'aiment
et c'est aussi ces quelques vers 10 à la
façon je crois de pierre fresnay dont
hélas je ne crois pas avoir réellement
la vie rêvée souvent vous avez tranché
et l'autre d'une femme inconnue
les kinés chaque foyer tout à fait la
même ni tout à fait une autre et même
compo calme combat et mon coeur
transparent pour elle seule elle a cessé
d'être un problème pour elle nous sommes
et les moteurs de mon front blade and
soul et s'offrir l'or à la hausse il a
aussi accusé un peu moins gentiment
d'ailleurs de chercher à imiter à grand
garçon blond qui fait du cinématographe
également avec élire jamais tourné non
plus et qui s'appelle jean marais la
voici sur les mêmes vers 2
de verlaine la voix je crois de gmail
j'étais souvent ce rêve étrange et
pénétrant d'une femme inconnue et que
j'aime et qui m'aiment et kinés chaque
fois ni tout à fait la même je t'ai
c'est une autre et même et ne comprendre
car elle me comprend et mon coeur
transparent pour elle c'est hélas cesse
d'être un problème pour elle c'est elle
et moi terre de mon front blaise est le
seul essai rafraîchir en pleurs meilleur
de ce qu'on m'accuse le plus de faire
d'une façon très précise c'est limité
mon petit frère gilbert b cran
si tu viens d'en bas annonce si tu
prends bien bave tu me portera chance et
nous irons très loin tu roulais te avait
violenté ya lancé
viens danser